It wasn't until the late 1980s, before the theory of multiple intelligences
really took hold, after being reshaped by Harvard psychologist Howard Gardner.
He agreed with g factor theories in one important way. Intelligence consist of
abilities in language, so are verbal and linguistics, or mathematical and
logical abilities, and our spatial abilities. And that scores in these three
domains were highly correlated. His fundamental argument however, was that
these three domains don't adequately capture the entire scope of intelligence,
and argued for at least five other forms of intelligence. Musical intelligence,
or bodily kinesthetic intelligence, or intrapersonal intelligence or
interpersonal intelligence, inner naturalistic intelligence